denise along with those rising numbers
you just pointed out statewide
hospitalizations
does remain a bit of a concern
especially among health leaders as they
look at the numbers
covid patients account for 31 of all
hospitalizations that's according to the
nevada hospital association
the latest data was reported during the
covid19
mitigation and management task force
meeting held earlier today
a big issue right now the inability to
transfer
440 patients statewide to other care
facilities
now the reasons vary from insurance
conservatorship or
prior covet status we only have four
hospitals in the state that are
as large as far as licensed beds
comparing that number so it's a it's a
big number it's like an
entire hospital in the state of nevada
full of people that could be discharged
the state received 36 000 doses of the
covid19 vaccine earlier this week
despite the cdc recommending anyone 65
years of age and older getting it
health leaders say the state cannot meet
that request
based on the allocation